[Musique]
nous sommes le 16 mars 2010 est
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités dédié à celles et ceux
qui font l'actualité dans le département
et nous parlerons cyclisme notamment
aujourd'hui mais aussi santé avec nos
invités en plateau patrick kane égaré
directeur de la cpam des yvelines il va
revenir sur son dernier ouvrage sa
dernière note une réflexion autour de
l'assurance maladie doit elle devenir
une assurance santé comment sauver notre
système actuel ces réponses à suivre et
puis également invité jean baptiste
dufour qui est à saint rémy les
chevreuse pour préparer la 25e édition
de l'agent racines c'est une grande fête
du vélo franciliens rendez vous prévu à
la fin du mois d'avril bon fort à tous
les deux elle soutenu en plateau patrick
kane les gars et je parlais de cette
note
en titre cette note qui est publié par
la fondation pour l'innovation politique
c'est un club de réflexion libéral
progressiste
avant de détailler un petit peu cette
note est et ce qu'elle contient
expliquez-nous les raisons de cette
publication est ce que c'est un acte
politique
c'est un acte politique qui peut
s'appliquer pour n'importe quel parti si
vous voulez parce que l'assurance
maladie est régulièrement déficit
les soins sont pas toujours suffisamment
bien remboursé et il ya des façons de
faire autrement c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'il faut privilégier l'accès à la
santé et pas l'accès aux soins c'est pas
la même chose
la santé c'est dû à 15% les soins mais
tout le reste c'est des mesures de
prévention c'est pour ça que vous avez
décidé de ce titre l'assurance maladie
qui évoluerait vers l'assurance santé on
parle de prévention part d'accompagner
avant que le malade déclare finalement
tout à fait c'est exactement ça vous
savez il ya deux solutions pour résoudre
le problème c'est agir sur la pertinence
des soins ce que tous les soins sont pas
justifiées du gaspillage
et puis aussi faire des mesures de
prévention parce qu'on sait que les
affections chroniques sont souvent dû à
une absence de prévention les gens
manquent de comportements vertueux en ce
qui concerne le sport ou une activité
si l'ampleur et où la nutrition et donc
en faisant attention à ça on arrive à
réduire considérablement ces affections
chroniques qui sont la principale cause
de dépenses et la cpm avait lancé des 98
1998 puis ensuite en 2011 cela s'est
généralisé c'est le dispositif que vous
connaissez bien pour l'avoir ligne mis
en place ces santé active alors ça
consiste en quoi santé active soit un
actif tout simplement c'est pour aider
les gens à changer de comportement il
faut leur faire des ateliers notre ami
qui enfin si l'on n'apprend pas le vélo
par un livre un moment il faut pratiquer
c'est la même chose on leur dit venez
dans des ateliers on va vous apprendre à
prendre soin de votre dos vous apprendre
comment bien vous nourrir comment faire
un minimum d'activités physiques et
après les gens vivent dans des clubs de
sport et ils le font ils se portent bien
mieux finalement l'accès aux soins ne
doit être que si vraiment on en a besoin
c'est précieux c'est très important et
ça aide les médecins quelque part à
exercer leur métier de se dire eh bien
ces gens là ils vont être accompagné
quelque part c'était ça l'idée
alors l'idée vous parlez vous pas c'est
parce que justement le dispositif a été
au fur et à mesure abandonnée ça aussi
on va y revenir parce que vous voyez
revenez longuement dans ce dans cette
note quels étaient les résultats malgré
tout santé active et voit les résultats
sur le département des yvelines par
exemple sur les yvelines et au départ
sur la sarthe on l'avait mesuré dans
l'étang dans les résultats étaient
absolument exceptionnel parce que les
gens ils consultaient - leur médecin il
avait moins de soins de kinésithérapie
qu'on se met moins de médicaments
voilà et donc tout ça c'est parce que on
les aider à gérer leur capital santé je
crois qu'il faut faire le pari de
l'intelligence et dire aux gens on va
vous aider changer votre façon de faire
voilà aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de gens
qui hésitent à se faire soigner parce
que ça coûte cher oui forcément
bien sûr cette logique là vous déplorez
que ce soit abandonné ce dispositif
santé active et oui c'est très dommage
parce que si vous voulez dans la mesure
où on dépense beaucoup en soins curatifs
un moment ou un autre qui a plus assez
d'argent et c'est au détriment de ceux
qui ont moins les moyens souvent le
moins accès et si on favorise cet accès
à la santé
c'est beaucoup plus facile d'un seul
coup prenons le sport sur ordonnance une
excellente idée mais aujourd'hui les
gens se sera pas remboursables il faudra
qu'ils aillent chez un coach de payer de
leur poche alors s'ils viennent dans
l'atelier santé et il n'y a pas de
problème puisque c'est gratuit c'est un
service public est aujourd'hui dans les
différentes propositions des candidats
ce qui revient
le plus c'est aussi de dérembourser à
une partie des médicaments notamment on
l'a on l'a entendu ça certains candidats
ça vous fait bondir
oui ça me fait bondir parce qu'il ya
d'autres solutions oui parce que là on
gagne finalement tous ces abus quelque
part de soi qui sont pas justifiées donc
normalement il n'y aurait pas besoin de
mettre qu'on appelle des coups de rabot
parce que c'est toujours la même
politique qui est mise en oeuvre et au
ca va à la faillite d'un système
la prévention avant tout et la france
est mal placée dans ce dispositif
scénique on comprend en vous écoutant ce
qui est pas du tout le cas par exemple
du canada parce que là vous dites
notamment vous fait un petit comparatif
internationaux fun canada ça marche
plutôt bien
oui ça marche plutôt bien et vous avez
aussi des équipes de soins aux états
unis qui mise beaucoup pour la
prévention jusqu'à 14 % des dépenses en
prévention et qui arrive à rembourser
les soins dits ambulatoire en ville à
80% alors qu'en france on a à peine
au-dessus de 50%
qu'en dit comment 75% c'est parce qu on
y inclut l'hôpital donc les gens on voit
bien aujourd'hui qu'elle est certes un
dépassement de tarif ya certains soins
qui sont peu plus en charge des lunettes
lors de piles l'orthodontie xterra sont
mal pris en charge et les gens ça leur
fait des restes à charge très important
vous êtes assez fataliste finalement
vous vous dites que les choses peuvent
changer malgré tout est ce que vous avez
le sentiment que y avoir une prise de
conscience sur ce domaine
moi j'aimerais bien parce que moi j'ai
essayé de les faire changer j'ai réussi
en partie puisque j'ai monté 22 espaces
interactifs jusqu'au mans encore une
fois pour des raisons financières on
arrête le système
j'ai maintenu par contre d espace
prévention il y en a ici à saint quentin
ville il y en a à poissy mais je crois
que quelque part j'ai beaucoup
d'encouragements tout plein de gens
m'encouragent à c'est ça qu'il faut
faire y compris des professeurs de
médecine et c'est donc la voie d'avenir
elle est là sinon on va on va jamais y
arriver les espaces prévention que vous
mentionnez qui existent notamment à 50
en mairie ils obtiennent quel résultat
qu'elle fréquentation et puis comment il
marche un petit peu si si des gens sont
intéressés mobile obtiennent une belle
fréquentation on peut y aller tous les
jours soit pour avoir de la
documentation soit pour s'inscrire dans
des ateliers et là il ya des coachs qui
les prendre en charge qui sont des
professionnels de santé qui l'aurait
dron à gérer leur capital santé
si on souhaite consulter cette note on
peut se la procurer
on peut se procurer pas vraiment parce
que il sait pas une édition comme les
autres n'ont pas les sur le site
fondapol point org
elle est en ligne il ya également une
vidéo voilà et le but c'est
d'interpeller aussi les politiques
forcément nous sommes en campagne
électorale mais j'imagine ajouté il ya
forcément une petite volonté de les
interpeller vaut rester en plateau avec
nous on va parler finalement un petit
peu santé encore puisqu'on va parler
cyclisme aussi avec vous et cette
opération cet événement jean racine
un bon moyen pour préserver sa santé
donc d'être responsable de l'événement
c'est quoi la jean racine à jean racine
si on devait résumer ce serait la grande
fête du vélo franciliens c'est à dire
que nous sur un événement on a cherché à
rassembler toutes les catégories toutes
les populations de vélo en ile-de-france
sur un lieu la laj racines c'est saint
rémy les chevreuse pour nous c'était
vraiment essentiel puisque aujourd'hui
en france il ya aucun événement qui
rassemble et ultra sportif et le le
randonneurs du dimanche la famille qui
sait soit très sportif soit très
découverte et pour nous pourrions venir
c'est important la cohésion la santé
c'est quelque chose c'est des thèmes qui
nous tiennent à coeur et puis on est on
veut faire la promotion du vélo travers
cet événement donc c'est ouvert à tous à
tout aussi bien cyclistes vététistes
randonneurs si vous souhaitez en savoir
un petit peu plus et la 25e édition
matière 25e édition c'est ça on a été
créé en 92 donc un petit moment déjà et
puis on a réussi à faire une belle
progression fur à mesure des années
maintenant on est entre 3000 et 4000
cyclistes sur le week-end et plus de 200
bénévoles pour le week-end donc c'est
vraiment une belle entreprise mais qui
reste avant tout bénévole c'est à dire
qu'on est un club une association de
1100 et une mairie qui nous soutient
financièrement pouvoir de plus le projet
est ce qu'il ya des nouveautés pour
cette 25e édition
beaucoup de nouveautés 25 ans et quart
de siècle voilà on a sorti une nouvelle
identité visuelle on a aussi développé
ce qu'on appelle le passage hier impasse
d'activité orienté pour le tourisme on a
aussi développé une jr kids pour les
enfants c'est à dire qu'on sait très
bien que les parcours sont pas forcément
accessibles pour les plus petits donc on
a fait un pack spécial 6 12 ans pour
qu'ils puissent dès le plus jeune âge à
prendre le vélo à prendre aussi le sport
puisque on se limite pas uniquement au
vélo on fait aussi des balades à pied
des balades à poney et puis on a créé
l'after jr qui est un peu le moment fort
du week-end ou
tout le monde s'est réuni le samedi soir
on laisse un peu tomber le vélo et puis
on n'est plus dans une dynamique de
cohésion on voit quelques images qui
passent à l'instar des précédentes
éditions
ça brasse aussi les différentes
générations là tout à fait objective tu
as fais tout à fait c'est l'objectif
faut savoir qu'on a un problème sur le
milieu du vélo lui mieux vélo de route
et plus âgées notamment aussi dans le
cyclotourisme que le milieu de vie d'été
et on a un peu cette scission qui se
fait entre les deux milieux et deux
n'arrive pas forcément à cohabiter
ensemble et nous vraiment l'objectif de
racine sy de récré de recréer une
dynamique dans toutes les pratiques du
vélo damman avoir juste l'amour de la
bicyclette vous nous disait c'est le
seul événement de cette envergure qui
n'existent ça veut dire que les
participants viennent de toute la france
je les participants viennent de toute la
france et même de pays voisins la
belgique le luxembourg la hollande on a
une grosse communauté dans le nord on
essaye d'avoir un peu plus dans le film
mais c'est toujours un peu plus
compliqué oui ils ont été un peu plus
joueur les alpes les pyrénées donc
forcément la veille de chevreuse les
intéressent moins malgré tout on a quand
même un fort rayonnement il avait le
choix est connu partout en france pour
être un endroit magnifique avec des
chemins incroyable
le but justement si c'est de promouvoir
un petit peu ce secteur tout à fait
développer le tourisme sur ce secteur
c'est qu'on est dans un cadre préservé
qu'on est dans un cadre magnifique avec
la haute vallée de chevreuse c'est
quelque chose qui est incroyable aussi
bien d'un point de vue sportif pour le
vététiste pour le vélo de route mais
aussi d'un point de vue tourisme avec
justement le pass gier on veut
promouvoir le territoire
c'est pour ça que la mairie nous
accompagne mais aussi le parc naturel
nous suit dans cette aventure
ce qui m'amène à parler d'environnement
aussi parce qu'il ya une démarche éco
responsable
alors ça se traduit comment cette
démarche éco-responsable on essaie
depuis plusieurs années de limiter notre
impact sur l'environnement en diminuant
les déchets en diminuant aussi tout ce
qui est le gâchis de nourriture qui
forcément dans tout événement tout bon
aux événements souffler un peu compliqué
on essaie de limiter les nuisances sur
la forêt sur le bruit etc
on essaye vraiment d'être dans une
démarche éco responsable en lien direct
sur le parc c'est à dire que le parc nos
projets nous propose des projets et nous
on accepte on joue le jeu finalement
cette opération 0 le 29 et 30 avril fin
du mois d'avril
jean racine pourquoi jean racine
jean racine parce que il ya un chemin en
fait qui part de la bidée vaux de cernay
et
dans la lettre de la bid pour royal
excusez moi et qui remontent jusqu'à 5
me cheuvreux en fait c'est pour ça qu'on
l'appelle l'agent leur culture
environnement sport en brassage de
générations
vous avez rempli tous les critères pour
accueillir le maximum de monde possible
on doit s'y inscrire si on veut
participer aux différents événements
c'est encore possible
tout à fait c'est encore possible
jusqu'au 15 avril pour les plus grands
parcours on est obligé de limiter
justement cette optique de limiter
l'impact on imite les l'inscription sur
le grand parcours par contre il est
toujours possible de s'inscrire sur
place pour les petits parcours 13 20 km
puis vous pouvez lire aussi simplement
pour découvrir l'ambiance ans avec les
staffs village d'animations qui est qui
est prévu et on renvoie au site internet
pour avoir toute la programmation ou
peut-être un dernier mot avec vous
patrick negar est votre regard en tant
que directeur de la cpam sur ce genre
d'initiative est ce que on peut imaginer
acpm partenaires par exemple de ce genre
de choses on est dans la prévention la
santé le bien-être et on le fait souvent
ça avec le parcours du coeur des choses
comme ça et je trouve très bien qu'ils
aient des jeunes qui s'investissent
parce que la voile est là si vous voulez
si c'est par là qu'il faut commencer
c'est très très bien je suis admiratif
il fait beaucoup de vélo d'enlever le
chevreuil aux tensions s'apaisent
présent jeune 29 et et le conte avril
merci à tous les deux d'être venu je
rappelle aussi cette note dans cet
ouvrage de patrick negar et le directeur
de la cpam des yvelines de l'assurance
maladie à l'assurance santé
une analyse sur le système de soins sur
les évolutions que vous préconisez
merci encore à vous c'est la fin de ce
set 8 les invités replay sur notre site
internet nouvelle édition ce sera lundi
aux horaires habituels
[Musique]